it's a good reminder that things things
were good and will be again they are
good
[Music]
I'm Sarah purchase FB and today I'm
gonna be looking at my wedding pictures
with my ex-husband it should be
interesting we met through friends well
technically we met in a bar but we knew
people so it feels a little less sleazy
she had a red top on I was smitten from
go and she was playing at
too-cool-for-school
it was not a match at first I really
wasn't interested but he grew on me and
he asked me out by like a month later
first date was on August the 9th Paris's
history and our here within I say about
a year of dating we moved in together
and then we got engaged it was a year
and a half later New Year's Eve at a
Black Crowes concert after one too many
drinks I said to her I have no ring I
have no money
but I love you I don't so the rest of my
life with you will you marry me she said
yes and we will hook up the next morning
she looked at me and said you still want
to do this yeah and my mom got sick she
got diagnosed with cancer and so we knew
that she was like gonna make it so he
actually did a justice of the peace
ceremony in December but the wedding
wedding I just wanted a big party it's
wonderful was awesome so after we got
married he switched jobs now we're
working all the time we don't really see
much of each other I'm getting up at
4:30 in the morning and I'm out think
that the things that affected the
marriage is just time away from each
other between his work and me doing
theater I was just getting more and more
frustrated not with her more with just I
really don't like the way this is my
life is going at this point the marriage
was good it was just got to a point we
weren't a married couple anymore we were
just two people living in the same house
and it needed to end it was that was the
end of the chapter we he actually is the
one that brought it up he was like I
think we should separate it was really
tough it was not easy we basically went
from roommates who get along to
roommates who don't get along who don't
even want to be in the same room with
each other obviously it hurt but looking
back it was the right move
for Apple Phyllis I moved to New Orleans
for six months I was not in a good place
drank way too much she was one of the
people I turned to why did you want to
do this video I wanted to find a way for
us to be friends I don't have a lot of
people and I I don't want to lose this
so I wanted to figure out a way to
remain a friend it'll just kind of
looking forward to just seeing these
pictures of people we haven't seen in
such a long time I think it might just
kind of give a little bit of like
closure I'm a little bit nervous
how are ya yeah waiting for people yeah
I'm so patient and she liked us
thanks B twice Buffalo Exchange cool
cool
so what lovely things did you say about
me uh you're a terrible person I was
glad to be out of this I don't know why
I'm doing it I'm gonna go hopefully this
isn't one of those things that in
concept it sounded like a good idea but
now after looking at it we're like
that's like a picture hey do it hey yeah
I really seriously haven't liked of
these in forever
oh look there's your hair there's my
hair yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
honestly there are a lot of people here
too that like we don't I don't see
anymore
yeah like here anymore so no it's a good
reminder that things things were good
and will be again they are good
[Music]
think that there's a stigma attached to
divorce it's always gotta be bad and it
doesn't always have to be bad you kind
of can choose depending on the scenario
just have as much respect for yourself
and for the other person is humanly
possible thank you for being here and
being you and not just walking away Sam
thanks for sticking it out with me and
wanting to still be my friend and making
sure I was okay when I got back always
cuz I wasn't I know could have easily
gone the other way and
[Music]
yeah okay I'm gonna hug you okay okay
[Music]
you
[Music]